going into a big client meeting see how
it goes did we get anything today you
know I'll be very I'm gonna throw you a
little bit of a curveball
that's 100% right I mean enough dollars
mm a long time ago and I don't mean some
of the cool stuff I mean when I made
$100,000 a year I literally thought I
made it you know in the micro with all
my crazy Jets ambition I can tell you
right now and I mean this because I want
you to hear from me my wants around this
area are far more about my legacy and
how I go to sleep at night then the
financial impacts for me I'm so much
more driven by legacy legacy is greater
than currency let's get into that
statement a little bit more one of my
favorite kind of I'm not even sure if
anybody's ever said it before I'm sure
somebody has but I'm all about it what
do I mean when I say legacy is greater
than currency you know I always go from
self inside of myself when I communicate
and talk to people and that's why I
think I'm able to articulate it because
it's it's my DNA right and so everything
I've ever done when I first got into the
liquor store industry with my dad all I
ever wanted to do was be the biggest
wine shop in the world
that was the number one agenda and so
what I talk about every business
decision that I ever made every one of
them was always based on my long term
legacy as being the biggest wine
retailer in the world that was my entire
thought process so when I was paying
myself nothing even though the business
was exploding and when I was letting
other managers take vacations in lieu of
my vacation time all these decisions
every one of them you can't skip every
one of them has to be about your
long-term legacy it can't be about the
dollars you're putting in your pocket in
this world where things are changing
every minute where players are changing
every minute if you're a hustler if
you're a very hard worker and you're
putting everything on the line put it
into your own personal brand just make
rent pay your bills
and keep building your personal bank
brand and always think of a big picture
the legacy who are you going to be
viewed at when it's all said and done
there are things
what's this oh my god what is it
porzingis sign jersey are you serious
yeah it's Gary's sneaker and a rice
krispy that is so rad and the reason I
keep pounding it isn't because of this I
truthfully believe all the way that if
every business decision you make from
hiring a secretary to buying what paper
you buy to every move you make if the
first question you ask is how does this
affect my legacy my long-term legacy
when it's all said and done I guarantee
the currency will be there at the end
the world is changing we're more
connected and your legacy you're
maneuvering your decision-making process
has to start at your long-term legacy
big picture always wins and so if you
take every decision out there that you
can make from who you're gonna be
surrounded by who are your friends right
people are looking for a short-term
traffic right you know Digg StumbleUpon
this and that silly things like that
well who your circle friends are or any
of those kinds of decisions mine or
decisions what conferences you go to
what what color's your website
everything everything has to start with
how is this going to impact my global
legacy and I guarantee you when you make
legacy decisions instead of quick cash
decisions or mid-range cash decisions
you're gonna win every time when you
come from that thought process when you
add it to the DNA game that we talked
about being your DNA when you add it to
not lying to yourself when you break
down these and you start putting these
pieces in place
you start winning
how you doing Babbitt very so a bunch of
meetings heading in now Chris Bradley
say what's up to the vlog was a blog
Chris probably incredible creative at
Bainer
going into a big climb meeting see how
it goes did we get anything today
sorry blog I kind of like it and that's
what you need to do you need to survive
and thrive you need to just keep it
going you know you got to pay your bills
so your family do all those things right
stay healthy have a little excess cash
just so you can buy a Wii or something
to make you happy but at all times all
times I on the price legacy is greater
than currency alright going a Knicks
game with Mark Yadkin head counsel super
interesting day just got a lot done not
leaving babbling with a whole whole lot
here's all I could tell you is when
you're in your [ __ ] zone when you're
doing your thing you're not scared of
anything even being in the middle of the
road just walking at it you're just not
[ __ ] scared you're just in your
[ __ ] zone and that's where I'm at
right now
I'm in my [ __ ] zone my CEO zone my
execution zone scared of nothing
zero gusik Robert [ __ ] Parrish double
zero Benoit Benjamin baby binoy Benjamin
baby for you MBA old-school fans
I'm just feeling great and I wish you
the ability to be in your [ __ ] zone
we're just all cliques you understand
all the variables you know all the moves
it's the reps you've seen it before
you've seen it before you've seen it
before that's where I'm at please if
anything after this video what is your
legacy is going to be the question you
need to ask yourself before you make any
kind of financial decision legacy my
friends is greater than currents
[Music]